martin biron paul journet michel suau g
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir ça fait 8 fois
qu'on l'a mans mais je vais vouloir
montrer l'un des messieurs la courbe on
voit la pole vous l'aviez aussi cette
courbe bleue dans votre journal ce matin
la coque du québec qui est vraiment
beaucoup plus accentuée que celle de
l'ontario de l'alberta la
colombie-britannique alors à la toute
fin parce que je posais différentes
façons la question on me laisse comme on
explique ça dans le fond et il parle de
discipline collective des québécois
versus celle des ontariens en écoute un
petit extrait c'est très courant revient
les gens aujourd'hui là ils sont chez
eux la pisse pose cette question comment
on est arrivé là
comment on est arrivé à et c'est avec
cette courbe là c'est ça qui se pose
comme question aujourd'hui les gens qui
sont chez eux puis regarde la période de
questions se demande qu'est ce que la
chef du parti libéral aurait fait de
différence avec à notre place qu'est ce
qu'elle aurait fait de différent un papa
nous donner une idée une suggestion
juste du chalard
quand vous aurez une réponse sur
pourquoi il y en a plus beaucoup au
québec
appelez moi je veux être le premier
intéressé peut-être qu'on va comprendre
tout dans quelques mois dans quelques
années je sais pas on va peut-être
comprendre dans quelques semaines quand
les gens donc penser qu en ontario les
suivent plus
je pense que c'est un élément de réponse
mais euroises le dis très poliment sont
plus disciplinés que nous à ce martin
donc c'est le sentiment gouvernement que
les autres rien suivent davantage les
consignes parce que à plusieurs égards
on est moins sévère en ontario qui s'il
ya moins de cas alors c'est le mystère
de tout seul martin je pense que c'est
pas aussi simple que ça c'est une partie
des réponses mais il ya d'autres choses
il ya beaucoup parlé du relâchement de
l'été et c'est vrai que cet été au
québec on s'est relâché beaucoup et le
gouvernement aussi s'est relâché il y
avait eu un gros crétin et ils y ont
pris ça plus calmes ils ont travaillé
notamment sur la charte des couleurs
avec des prescriptions là quand on
rentrait dans la zone orange la zone
rouge et y ont hésité eux mêmes à
appliquer ce qu'ils avaient défini comme
les conséquences d'entrer dans une zone
ou dans une autre alors on a su
rapidement au mois d'août par exemple
que les bords il y avait beaucoup de
contamination dans les bars que c'était
les 20 30 ans qui se contaminent est
davantage mais ils ont été les derniers
contaminer les bars ça devenait
difficile de les recombiner même chose
quand leur rentrée scolaire est arrivé
on s'est rendu compte que la
contamination la fourchette c'était les
10 30 ans alors là on s'est dit des
éclosions c'est dans les écoles on a
persisté avec les activités
parascolaires et alors c'est pas une
science parfaite pas exact mais
finalement ils ont su retrouver avec la
tempête parfaite
oui il n'ya pas un seul facteur mais la
responsabilité des québécois leur
attitude
c'est assurément une des raisons cela
dit
le gouvernement peut pas seulement
accusé les québécois parce qu il a
lui-même ses responsabilités leur l'air
de s'en délester et aussi parce que
c'est une dynamique qui se joue à deux
souvenez vous quand au début au milieu
du printemps dernier le gouvernement
dise les beaux jours arrivent enfin
l'été arrive et soul sister un message
pour cadre un certain relâchement après
le confinement et c'est normal que les
gens posent des questions puis l'extrait
que vous avez présenté ou dominique
anglade se fait savonner par monsieur
legault parce qu'elle ne propose pas de
solution mais le rôle de l'opposition
elle n'a pas une armée de fonctionnaires
à sa disposition pour accoucher de
solutions pour évaluer les conséquences
de chaque solution c'est son rôle avec
ses moyens limités de demander au
gouvernement
qu'est-ce qu'il fait pourquoi il
pourquoi le fait qu'elles sont les
conséquences et qu'est ce qu'il aurait
pu faire de différent donc le
gouvernement oui il peut accuser les
autres mais il doit aussi répondre aux
questions difficiles parce qu'elle
apparaisse courbes elle ne ment pas ça
va mal au québec par rapport aux autres
provinces
il faut savoir pourquoi oui exactement
remarquer que monsieur dubé c'est après
quand même 14 minutes avant parce que je
voulais que j'ai vraiment mener sur la
discipline des québécois mais il ne
voulait pas dire c'est une veulent pas
ils sont conscients qu'il ne veut pas
dire parce qu'on n'est pas bon on n'est
pas discipliné mais en même temps on
comprend que dans leur tête c'est une
est un facteur michel sait qui est
indéniable c'est certainement un facteur
mais moi j'ai noté une chose dans votre
entrevue que monsieur tués
c'est qu'il a la même énergie qui avait
monsieur legault printemps de comparer
le québec avec du comptable on peut pas
regarder on peut pas comparer avec
l'ontario peut pas comparer avec
persistante
pourquoi oui il faut comparer voir
quelles sont les meilleures pratiques
puis pourquoi il s'en tire mieux que
nous c'est la base la gouvernance ou ci
a demandé à les adopter les meilleures
pratiques d'ailleurs pourquoi nous on
est différent mais il ya une chose qui
est assez différente ça c'est assez
évident c'est les pénuries de personnel
puis la gestion du personnel dans notre
système de santé
il ya eu 800 postes d'infirmières libre
dans la région de la capitale nationale
à québec 800 600 personnes qui sont
partis du système pas tout
qui fait peur c'est ça qui leur famille
c5 c6 les sbc chose madame on t il
disant délesté l'inter mais froid qui
viendra pas faire d'autres opérations
les émissions dede l'accueil au centre
au ch à celle des erreurs n'étaient pas
des lapins épicé la catastrophe est
arrivée pareille l'asepsie postaux ça
c'est trop facile on a quelque chose de
différent un système de santé puis la
fin c'est la gestion de personnel les
facs y en avait partout même dans le
reste du canada les comparons allons
chercher les meilleures méthodes
ailleurs ça vaut peut-être la peine
plutôt le dire on peut gérer se comparer
aux autres
québec jusqu'à ce que le gouvernement
ait quand même hésitant à agir a confiné
à mettre la pression parce que la
stratégie du gouvernement dans les
dernières semaines c'est une stratégie
qui était basée sur la popularité de
monsieur legault et sur son influence on
a voulu faire peur au monde monsieur
legault s'est présenté à plus d'une
reprise en conférence de presse avec le
ton grave en disant il faut qu'on se
console qu'on réduise nos contacts et on
a beaucoup misé là dessus pour préserver
les écoles pour préserver l'économie et
là on a on frappe le mur comme disaient
les minimes état que je nombre c'est
triste à dire mais tant que le nombre de
décès et d'hospitalisations n'allait pas
monter c'est très difficile convaincre
les gens qu'on est devant la même genre
de menaces là en terme de communication
c'était pas facile non plus la pole mais
c'est encore plus difficile quand vous
changez de temps et quand vous changer
de position je pense qu'on reconnaît
tous que c'est un virus pour lequel les
connaissances change 8 la situation
pandémique elle aussi changent vite donc
il faut s'ajuster mais il ya certains
certains changements de décisions qui
sont plus difficiles à comprendre par
exemple celui sur l'application covin ou
le bc le gouvernement dise une chose une
semaine après dit le contraire c'est
peut-être un peu plus difficile pour les
gens à suivre
cela dit si on continue de si on se
compare pour ce qui est de la
communication en ontario même si leur
lutte contre le virus vaut mieux aussi
ils ont de sérieux problèmes de
communication parce que partout on fait
face à la même difficulté si on essaie
de faire un confinement partielle de
confirmer de confiner certains secteurs
et pas d'autres ça devient terriblement
difficile à expliquer pourquoi on a fait
telle ou tel choix
en quoi est-ce que c'est cohérent ou non
et on le vue d'un ford a été écrite
script il eut aussi le bredouillé il
cafouille en essayant d'expliquer
certaines de ces mesures
bon les écoles parce que c'est vraiment
extraordinairement important ce qui se
passe je vous montre un tableau du
nombre de deux d'école où il ya au moins
un cas et de classes qu'on a dû fermer
on va le on va le trouver c'est ça
augmente à tous les jours voyez-vous
écoles avec au moins 15 729 63 de plus
qu'hier classes fermées 936 108
depuis hier donc ça augmente mais bien
sûr que ça se promène dans communauté
dont c'est normal ça se promènent chez
les adolescents elle se lit chez les
élèves aussi la question c'est est-ce
que les mesures annoncées hier un jour
sur deux pour ce concert 4 secondaire 5
le masque en tout temps pour les élèves
à ce que c'est de nature à améliorer
beaucoup les choses à ce que cette
nature à inquiéter
je vous fais un temps d'un échange donc
aujourd'hui et on revient ensuite où est
votre bilan en matière de connexion des
familles ainsi que le nombre de
tablettes ou sont-elles rendue de façon
spécifique on est équipé on a fait nos
devoirs
on est capable aussi même de fournir des
clés interne pour donner accès et en
aide à des familles qui n'avaient pas
les moyens de se payer internet jamais
on doit fermer une école sur mambo à
fermer une classe pour les élèves de se
barkat et 5 qui devront fréquenté
l'école un jour sur deux on est capable
aussi de faire de fournir des liaisons
ethernet pour ces familles là parce que
je rappelle hier on n'a pas bien
l'extrême me steyer je rappelle que les
pédiatres
pour eux ce n'est pas une bonne idée du
tout le masque pour les adolescents tout
en classe martin est ce que une journée
sur deux secondaire iv secondaire 5
les gens sont ainsi équiper les écoles
sont équipées pour donner des tablettes
et ordinateurs y en a qui n'ont pas
internet quand ça fonctionne mais il ya
encore trois mille trois cent soixante
mille foyers au québec qui n'ont pas
internet alors là ça devient petit peu
plus compliqué pour eux ça c'est un fait
et ils y auront pas internet la semaine
prochaine est probablement sous pas
d'ici la fin du mandat
ça c'est une chose ayant des enfants
dans cette situation là il ya des c les
directions d'école qui vont devoir faire
cette gestion là et s'assurer que les
enfants ne soient pas seuls chez eux un
jour sur 200 ordinateurs les outils
devront garantir des outils ça va être
bon à montréal on devrait avoir une
meilleure gestion mais en dehors de
montréal ça va devenir certainement
beaucoup plus compliqué dont paul est ce
qu'on est prêt puis je vous entends sur
le la vie des pédiatres également points
mais peut-être qu'on peut commencer avec
la vie des pédiatres c'est pas toutes
les mesures qu'ils dénoncent avec la
même intensité eux ce qui les dérange le
plus c'est la fin du parascolaire puis
du sport étudiant c'est vraiment leur
principale préoccupation
la seconde c'est l'enseignement à
distance à temps partiel pour le
secondaire 4 5 et ce qui arrive loin
derrière c'est le port du masque le cep
à angres aux irritants pour eux
pour ce qui est du parascolaire et du
support baisse et que souvent c'est
vraiment ce à quoi particulièrement les
jeunes garçons qui sont plus à risque de
décrocher s'accroche pour finir est ce
qui explique beaucoup leur inquiétude
c'est que eux ils pensent pas que ça va
durer seulement en gros ils pensent que
les mauvaises nouvelles vont se
poursuivre et que l'interdiction qui est
censé être temporaire va se prolonger
pour ce qui est de l'enseignement à
distance c'est difficile de dire en ce
moment si ça fonctionne
c'est que l'enseignement à distance est
moins bien qu'en classe mais le minimum
au moins ça serait de fournir les outils
technologiques puis en ce moment on a
plus de crainte que des certitudes à
savoir est ce que tout le monde va avoir
du masque les gens vont avoir du
matériel non mais on sait qu'il ya des
gens qui vont être échappé ça c'est
certain la question c'est à quel point
ils seront nombreux
oui michel c'est un petit mot sur les
adolescents le problème de l'association
des médias c'est qu'ils y ont brûlé trop
épais là je devais la génération
sacrifiée la génération sacrifiée
je serai alors c'est quoi exactement
les agresseurs ont quand même une
certaine résilience je sais c'est pas
l'idéal c'est sûr c'est pas une bonne
idée d'arrêter le sport études sauf qu
est ce qu on a quelque chose de plus
intel 2 qui peut leur place est dans une
situation de pandémie où la pratique du
sport par exemple pourrait être un foyer
de contagion
ça aussi ça fait partie du dow aussi
alors il faut pour faire la part des
choses que les pédiatres nous disent
pour faire attention si ça dure trop
longtemps nous avons depuis lors des
shows 28 on est très bonne idée je pose
est qu'elle survienne le 28 jours est ce
que ça marche une fois devient toujours
mais sur l'urgente papin d'alcool de 1
20 mars
on sait bien là on le fait en février en
tout cas on se quitte sur les actions
les excuses d'état du gouvernement du
québec à la famille chaque orane martin
on va d'abord écouter c'est très courant
revient sur le service public québécois
au failli à son devoir envers madame et
chacun l'étal d'avoir de frais la même
unité de même respect à tout le monde
peu importe son origine peu importe son
sexe
peu importe la couleur de sa peau tout
le monde a le droit au respect donc
aujourd'hui je veux au nom de l'état
québécois au frais mes excuses à la
famille aux proches et à la communauté
de jaws et chacun
les excuses que présente aujourd'hui le
premier ministre au nom de l'ensemble
des québécoises et des québécois sont
nécessaires elles sont nécessaires pour
exprimer une fois de plus notre rejet le
plus complet de raciste systémique que
subissent les autochtones
parce que oui le risque systémique
existe parce que oui les solutions
existent parce que si je refuse que leur
système est exaucé pas parce que je dis
que les québécois sont racistes banon
devons reconnaître que nous avons failli
que madame et chacun a vécu
l'inacceptable ou zurich la
responsabilité de ce drame et
collectives parce qu'elle n'est pas la
seule
le rapport de la commission vieux démons
à la lumière de nombreux témoignages
tour de table michel c'est d'abord là
dessus c'est assez étonnant de voir des
débats il sait faire toutes sortes de
circonvolutions pour ne pas dire assez
systémique alors que cette
responsabilité collective c'est ça que
ça veut dire quelque part mais enfin tu
le vaux fait ce qu'il fallait faire cela
dit qu'il fallait des excuses
officielles et qu'elle ne tarde pour
qu'on ne soit que la communauté n'est
pas allé demander si c'est aussi
important que de faire des excuses puis
des ponts qui ont été rétablies en tout
cas reparti un pari en partie mais y
avait eu plusieurs que semblables à ceux
dans le rapport bien sûr que ces décotes
n'avait pas été philippe n'avait pas été
mis sur facebook donc c'est nécessaire
de s'excuser mais quand même c'est pas
un précédent et malheureux ça risque de
ne pas être dernier on a malheureusement
on a fait des parallèles en disant que
c'est un peu comme ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis où un homme qui était
carrément tué par les policiers devant
les caméras réveiller à nouveau
mouvement black like the matters bayeux
d'autres cas par la suite il y en avait
eu avant donc pour ça que les excuses
c'est bien mais c'est insuffisant pour
agir et la première chose à faire pour
agir c'est de reconnaître que ce n'est
pas qu'un problème individuel de
certaines personnes racistes mais aussi
un problème collectif
appelez ça comme vous voulez systémique
discrimination systémique peu importe
pour reconnaître qu' il ya une part
culturels institutionnels
la responsabilité est collective et un
contrat dépasse la nation qui dépasse
l'addition du raciste que certains
individus du peuvent avoir marre tienne
conclusion le gouvernement reconnaît en
coulisses que celle on l'a dit les
suites à donner au rapport vient qui a
été déposée il ya un an et ce qui est
arrivé à joliette quand même monsieur
legault ne pas tergiverser sur la
question des excuses et il a choisi le
jour des funérailles de joyce et chaque
one et c'est ça fait partie sur narratif
mais on s'en remet pas merci beaucoup à
vous trois bonne fin de soirée
au revoir à la prochaine salut au revoir